albert dupontel bonsoir pardon pour
commencer de ne pas avoir eu le temps de
voir votre film je le regrette mais je
peux vous dire que j'en ai déjà beaucoup
entendu parler et en bien alors comme ça
vous êtes vilain vous nous avez fait des
frayeurs vous êtes arrivé en retard mais
vous êtes vilain dans ce film est est ce
que ce ne serait pas par hasard un tout
petit peu jeudi à un poil
autobiographique dont ont eu tout bon
donc ce qui veut dire que vous êtes
investi dans un rôle qui vous plaisait
de créer en fait ce vilain c'est quelle
est l'origine de cette histoire que vous
mettez à l'écran aujourd'hui nous invite
sur un film catherine frot d'accord
alors pari réussi apparemment catherine
frot qui est paraît-il est une
formidable partenaire pour vous comment
est ce que vous avez pu faire j'allais
dire pour être est le partenaire devant
la caméra et en même temps réalisateur
donc derrière la caméra c'est ça devait
être un boulot demain non non en étant
payé tout simplement pardon en étant
payé tout simplement à c'est ça qui est
motivant n'y avait pas une envie
artistique de création non moi je mérite
mon salaire ce qu'ils peuvent votre
casse si vous voyez pas mes films mais
non c'est pas vu le film vous allez
parce que je vous en ai demandé pardon
publiquement
tout simplement parce que j'ai pas parce
que j'ai un métier justement moi aussi
aussi je vous appelle et voilà qui n'est
pas de faire ces jeunes et le choix des
films de voir les films avant d'inviter
des gens très bien merci je vous
remercie infiniment votre accueil
merci beaucoup bonne soirée bonne soirée
à vous aussi et merci de
donnez l'occasion de vous avoir salué
très rapidement l'occasion s'était en
fait le festival du film de beauvais
c'est amusant ce qui peut se passer sur
un plateau de télévision et nous allons
nous quitter là dessus je ne me reste
plus qu'à vous remercie